[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma intanto buonasera volevo partire
visto che avevamo parlato di fagioli
bianchi cosa avremmo fatto io e molti
miei amici
se avessimo trovato in una stanza del
sacco di fagioli bianchi
il primo pensiero sarebbe stato che cosa
ne avremmo fatto questo credo che oggi
fa la differenza di non solo di quelli
della mia età ma neanche molti giorni e
di capire subito cosa possiamo fare con
quello che troviamo specie quando questo
qualcosa che non ci aspettavamo sembra
definizione stessa di serendipity e
senza la serendipity credo che non
abbiamo risposte da offrire agli
studenti della professoressa che mi ha
preceduto
penso che oggi dai nuovi problemi e
nuove sfide che ci attendono
riducono l'età a tal punto che davanti
ai nuovi temi professori e studenti
maestri allievi sono assolutamente
paritari davanti alle nuove questi oli
questo purtroppo ne mette in questione
tutta la questione dell'educazione
questi fenomeni sono come dire ormai sul
tavolo di tuttino anche signora che mi
ha proceduto prima sta riducendo la
distanza tra maestro e allievo c'è anche
un tema oggi che quello delle priorità
che ci stanno attendendo penso che ormai
c'è un rumore di fondo nelle menti delle
persone nel pianeta
il tono è una questione fondamentale che
per la prima volta percepiamo che la
presenza del
specie umana sulla terra non è più così
certa e questo è questione di fondo sta
cambiando completamente le priorità
se noi ci pensiamo il primo pensiero che
ci viene sulla cultura che essa è già
stata salvata
così come la conoscevamo ma che per
questi nuovi temi che cos'è la cultura
che cos'è la héritage forse è un momento
che dobbiamo sospendere queste questioni
non solo abbiamo queste questioni ma
scopriamo anche che il pianeta sta
costruendo una propria intelligenza sta
costruendo diciamo di più il nostro c'è
un nuovo suo cervello e questo avrà un
enorme influenza sul futuro degli umani
e degli umani sulla terra questo
cervello una caratteristica è stato
educato da noi ed è stato ed è composto
dai frammenti della nostra vita siamo
anche in un momento in cui tutte queste
informazioni si stanno muovendo in uno
spazio che ogni giorno più limitato la
fisica ci dice che non possiamo
scambiare più informazioni che un numero
finito e che quindi quello di cui stiamo
parlando non sistema in completa
evoluzione
la seconda cosa stiamo assistendo a
fenomeni usa toni molto interessanti che
è il diffusione di internet ma di un
inter nel nuovo nei prossimi anni avremo
miliardi di nuovi utenti che avranno una
caratteristica sono le alfabetizzati e
parleranno con questo strumento con il
vocale e non avranno bisogno di leggere
e di scrivere ma questo lo potete
constatare già anche nelle nostre nuove
anche qui nelle marche quante persone si
sono di alfabetizzate da quando hanno
imparato a leggere a scrivere
eppure usano le nuove tecnologie in
maniera
efficace questo qui sarà strumento di
evoluzione ci aiuterà a rimettere in
moto tante situazioni
oppure no
l'altra cosa che stiamo capendo l'enorme
capacità e al nostro cervello rispetto
alla competizione con l'altro cervello
che sta producendo la terra e quindi la
nostra capacità in questo momento è
proprio di efficientare la mente e lo
stesso processo che oggi abbiamo con le
megalopoli è inutile continuare a
lavorare di urbanistica architettura
cazzate varie
la cosa più importante efficientare la
metropoli è questo
sono i temi che credo sono i più
importanti per tutti noi e anche per i
giovani oggi avere cura significa anche
pensare semplicemente a mettere a punto
dei sistemi per farci degli autotest
un'auto test e ci aiuta essere più
efficienti ma anche a suo modo ad essere
creativi
volevo farvi vedere una cosa che abbiamo
fatto prendendo insiste un sistema di
lettura dell'immagine che voi trovate
anche online e dove noi possiamo fare
interrogare a questo sistema dei
prodotti che noi abbiamo creato e
cercare di capire da loro che cosa sono
gli effetti di questa ricerca sono molto
curioso abbiamo dato a questo sistema
che potete usare anche voi erede
questo sistema che trovate online e ha
mai chiesto di chi è che cos'erano
questi oggetti della storia del design
italiano
beh qui vedete la risposta sulla famosa
poltrona di mendini e la trovo molto
interessante se fosse stato un mio
progetto
probabilmente mi avrebbe aiutato a
disegnarne qualcun'altro cambiare il
nome ha comunque a costruire una
narratività asimmetriche potente questo
è molto interessante no la cosa
interessante che sono oggetti che noi
abbiamo nelle case e sottomessi alla
capacità dell'intelligenza artificiale
di riconoscerli la mandiamo in in dubbio
non riesce a leggerli ma perché perché
sono dei prodotti asimmetrici della
nostra creatività questo è vero che una
sedia comodissima ma è anche un oggetto
molto strano che non ricade negli
standard prof più frequenti della sedia
questo tuiach ero molto curioso
questa ancora meglio è molto
interessante perché l'analisi che fanno
voi lo tenete sia quell'oggetto sia
vista di fronte sia che sia visto in
prospettiva sia che ci ha visto di
fianco ecco questo anche molto
interessante come risposta di questo
pure
questo è un caso interessante perché è
evidente non c'è abbastanza memoria di
questo oggetto in quel cervello che si
sta in quella intelligenza che si sta
formando e quindi non è ancora in grado
di leggerlo di ritrovarlo nella storia
dell'umanità questo ci siamo quasi a
questo è bizzarro e penso che questi
sono come dire risposte mandalay che che
dovrebbero farci riflettere sui nostri
sistemi attraverso cui oggi molti
giovani operano perché l'intelligenza
artificiale opera come molti giovani lo
vediamo nelle scuole di design scuole di
creatività dove pochissimi riescono
perché si auto addestrano esattamente
come l'intelligenza artificiale cioè
corrono immagini online in continuazione
senza fissare esattamente un concetto o
un progetto questo si fissa nella coda
dell'occhio del cervello e genera poi
delle cose che esistono
adesso vedremo un'altra esercizio che mi
ha fatto questo molto interessante
famosa lampade di castiglioni questo
questo è un esercizio che è stato fatto
da più laboratori richiedere
intelligenza artificiale di disegnare
delle sedie e come vedete le sedie che
vedrete sono le sedie che si vedono
negli ultimi anni nel fuorisalone a
milano fatti dai giovani designer e
questa è l'ennesima prova che
l'addestramento porta a risultati simili
queste macchine sono state addestrate
tele vedete quante ne avete viste per
qualcuno di golf al design e avrà
disegnate anche lui
l'addestramento dell'intelligenza
artificiale è cominciato tanti anni fa
per quanto riguarda il riconoscimento
facciale questa è stata la prima a serie
di immagini che sono state introdotte
era una signora giapponese e ovviamente
fin dall'inizio è l'espressione che
ricostruisce chi noi siamo scusate mi
vedete un po il sistema attraverso cui è
stato prodotto la riconoscibilità
facciale
il secondo gruppo di immagine era un
gruppo di ricercatori americani e poi un
gruppo di ricercatori dell'olivetti
questi sono ancora al giorno d'oggi
fondamenti della riconoscibilità del
volto umano
il mio amico marco cadioli rimesso in
serie con le immagini con i dieci
immagini e vedete in questo incredibile
montaggio che contiene tutte le
espressioni umane in un lampo di tempo
e qui passiamo il tema molto divertente
qui invece è stato chiesto di dipingere
un quadro un ritratto e non solo la
l'intelligenza artificiale ha scelto la
tecnica le cose ma se anche firmata
attraverso il sistema attraverso cui ha
generato l'immagine avremmo potuto
immaginare che avrebbe disegnato no un
dipinto una fotografia non si sa ma
probabilmente questa è la banalizzazione
della storia della pittura
dell'ottocento
qui vedete soliti sistemi che fosse
conoscete meglio di me
questo per esempio è quello che vedete
adesso sono lavori di artisti sui
sistemi della riconoscibilità affacciare
vestiti sono persone di cui abbiamo
pochi dati e quindi la memoria stessa va
a cercare nell'arte del passato per
comporre la totalità della persona
questi sono ancora più interessanti ma
questi sono i ritratti che faceva bacon
negli anni 50 sono assolutamente
identici
cioè se arriva a ottenere lo stesso
risultato
questa qui è una questione molto
complessa perché possiamo chiederci se
poi queste cose possono rientrare in un
concetto di serendipity cioè una
sorpresa
oppure di mancato funzionamento di
limitato funzionamento però in questo
caso possiamo dire sia nel caso di bacon
che di quel lavoro precedente che è
molto creativo come mancato
funzionamento che cosa significano
queste cose e che oggi per me
siamo arrivati un momento in cui siamo
obbligati ad essere ottimisti che cosa
significa che se siamo per forza
ottimisti riusciamo a continuare a
creare a interessarsi a produrre con
tutte le asimmetrie del caso ma anche
credo con una partecipazione molto
intensa da parte delle persone di età
molto diverse
questo mi sembra ormai accertato
questa è una cosa molto più interessante
che quando noi cerchiamo noi stessi
nella riconoscibilità facciali
il prodotto che ci assomiglia non è una
fotografia è la composizione di tutte le
informazioni che abbiamo su di noi e
quindi di fatto questo io non esiste
però è la persona che rimarrà per sempre
e si potrà ricomporre per sempre qui
vorrei tornare al primo problema che
quello dell'educazione che qui avete
visto l'educazione della macchina che
però apparentemente procede con sistemi
simili a quella degli umani abbiamo
fatto anche esercizi su produrre dei
disegni da colorare generati dall
intelligenza artificiale il risultato è
ancora una volta molto simile a quelli
usati per gli urali
questo significa che noi siamo in un
momento interessantissimo perché se
uniamo quel tutto queste cose cui
apparentemente non riusciamo a trovare
la logica se l'è mescoliamo con la prima
affermazione che vi dicevo che siamo
ormai sensibile all'argomento della
nostra permanenza del pianeta forse
questo ci spinge a forme di creatività
tutte nuove
i nuovi temi necessitano di risposte
completamente nuove che non dipendono
più dalla tradizione
luogo perché sono problemi che non sono
mai esistiti sul pianeta
tante volte le soluzioni trovano anche
suggestioni ispirazioni nelle forme
primarie della storia degli umani
per esempio la preistoria è molto più
interessante oggi che la storia ha però
una caratteristica la preistoria e
condivisa sul pianeta e oggi potremmo
dire che gli umani si assomigliano
sempre di più non tanto per la
globalizzazione ma forse perché stiamo
tornando a temi antecedenti alla
formazione culturale storica prima
parlavamo di questo territorio possiamo
leggerlo in tanti modi no è anche un
territorio dove ancora si partecipa a
creare un mondo che non è molto attuale
non basta vedere quanta gente mangia i
maiali quanta gente qui mangia
tantissimo e poi possiamo dire sì siamo
tutti felici perché viviamo così abbiamo
le moto ci avviamo il territorio bello
rovinato ma non importa sembra
apparentemente verde questo problema
dell'apparenza dovrebbe anche come 10 è
il vero tema è anche il tema di quelle
immagini
cioè capire scientificamente qual è la
realtà in cui noi
e dentro lì come noi possiamo continuare
a vivere a una sola condizione e
ricreando i rapporti con le altre forme
viventi e senza questo contratto non ci
saranno i nuovi progetti di là ho visto
una moto non so cosa serve
stranamente era il primo piano è ancora
un altro del pase una moto del passato
con la benzina le cose e penso che i
nuovi temi sono i veri stimoli per la
creatività la condizione di essere dagli
enti e netti cioè di in questo momento
non possiamo permetterci credo successo
molti temi la continuità e questo credo
è una cosa su cui tutti noi dobbiamo
riflettere e questo sta anche cambiando
l'educazione educare significa essere
persone oggi di diverse età davanti a
problemi che dobbiamo affrontare insieme
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]